Just before we get into Today’s video, I
want to give a random YouTube plug.
Sometimes I’m browsing around YouTube and I stumbled across a channel that I think it’s
criminally unsubscribed and that channel I
want to tell you about today is DUMB MONEY.
‘We are dumb money, we quit our day jobs
to do this…’
This is more business focused channel.
I’m not getting paid for saying this or
anything like that.
It’s just a channel I stumbled across and
I really liked.
They have a few thousands subscribers and
I’d like to send them some more.
So you can have their links on the description
below.
So now, let’s get on to this.
Nobody likes dictators but… what happens
when the alternative is even worse?
This is the story of Libya.
This is the story of former prime minister
Gaddafi’s rise and fall.
Libya has more oil reserves than America.
In fact, they have the biggest oil reserves
in Africa.
Then again, production-wise, they are far
below most of the famous oil countries, even
below Iran, despite Trump’s sanctions.
Why?
Well… ever heard of the Arab Spring?
After that period of uprisings and general
destabilization, Libya is the country that
ended up worst off.
Basically, there’s a lesson to be learned
from Libya: no matter how badly you think
a country is doing… it can do even worse.
Have you ever seen the movie ‘The dictator’,
by Shasha Baron Cohen?
Well, this parody was pretty much inspired
by MUHAMMAR EL GADDAFI: one of the craziest
dictators of all time, who ruled Libya for
decades.
Gaddafi was well known for having his own
harem of about 30 women.
This harem was known as his Amazonian Guard.
From the early 1970s onward, they remained
close by his side at all times.
Sometimes the women took bullets for Gaddafi.
One woman died and two were injured when the
Libyan leader was attacked in 1998.
Some of the conditions to become part of the
guard were to make an oath of virginity, dress
in camouflage, and maintain perfect nail polish
and makeup.
Of course, there are thousands of reports
of rape and abuse that came to light after
Gaddafi’s death.
Surprisingly, during his lifetime, Gaddafi
always congratulated himself as a protector
of Women’s rights in the Arab World.
But not only that!
The self-proclaimed Brother Leader had a massive
fear of heights and could not fly more than
eight hours over water… he also had some
peculiar demands when he stayed in hotels:
he always had to stay on the first floor and
he would not climb more than 35 steps.
So yes, if we make a video ranking the most
extravagant dictators of all time, Gaddafi
would definitely be in the top 10.
Diplomacy-wise, Gaddafi is one of those dictators
that went from being America’s worst enemy
to a friend of the US before becoming, yet
again, the man America loved to hate.
And now Libya is a chaotic state, where even
foreign oil companies have to make deals with
warlords in order to keep pumping oil.
Don’t believe me?
Just look at this news.
Repsol oil fields in Libya go back to Business
after a deal with raiders
In this case, a Spanish oil company, Repsol,
had an agreement with the Libyan National
Oil corporation in 2008.
Back then, they just had to agree with the
dictatorship to do business.
Then, during the Libyan civil war, a different
warlord took over Repsol facilities.
And, finally, after a lot of struggle, in
2018, the oil company had to make an agreement
with some local tribe.
What happened here?
What’s going on in Libya today?
Why would an oil company make a deal with
a war lord?
Today, we’re going to answer all of these
questions but, before we do, let’s take
a look back at the history.
THE MAN YOU LOVE TO HATE
Ever seen the movie Naked gun?
It starts with a scene where Gaddafi appears
next to the other bad guys of the moment:
Idi Amin, Ayatollah Khomeini, Gorbachev, Yasser
Arafat, Fidel Castro… they’re all gathered
in a room, making a plan to defeat the US.
Yes, my dear viewers, there was a time when
Gaddafi was considered one of the worst evils
on the planet.
Why?
Let’s go back in time.
Libya was an Italian colony for several decades
in the early 1900s, then it became a monarchy
until in 1969, Gaddafi rose to power.
He believed in so-called Arab Socialism, a
strange cocktail of centralized economy, secularism,
and cult of personality.
He even developed his own political philosophy,
writing an extremely influential book, “The
Green Book”.
He made countless appearances at Arab and
international gatherings, standing out not
just with his outlandish clothing, but also
because of his blunt speeches and odd behaviour.
Even some socialist parties in Europe were
sponsored by him.
Oil could pay for a lot of influence in the
rest of the world.
But unlike other countries like Egypt, he
didn’t nationalize oil.
He put harder conditions on foreign oil companies,
but that was all.
He challenged oil executives by stating "people
who have lived without oil for 5,000 years
can live without it again for a few years
in order to attain their legitimate rights".
That was a bold move.
A move that helped him secure a majority share
of oil company revenues while, at the same
time, maintaining an effective oil industry
in the country.
Despite the socialism and the dictatorship,
Libya was still open for business.
Repsol says Libyan oil nationalisation unlikely
And, let’s be honest here… the formula
worked.
Many European companies like ENI, TOTAL and
Repsol kept doing business with Libya.
Money came in, oil came out.
And the country’s citizens benefited.
For years, Libya had the highest Human Development
Index of any African country, at certain points,
surpassing South Africa.
This increase was accompanied by a very controversial
foreign policy.
During the 1980s and 1990s, Gaddafi aligned
himself with the Eastern Bloc, Fidel Castro’s
Cuba and openly supported movements like the
Irish Republican Army and the Palestinian
Liberation Front.
But none of this would have been a big deal
if it wasn’t for the terrorism.
Libya’s government was known to participate
or aide in terrorist acts.
Many Marxist-inspired guerrilla groups or
even terrorist groups were funded by Gaddafi.
But the defining moment was the bombing of
a nightclub in Berlin where American soldiers
used to frequent.
Many Libyan spies were involved in this.
And America didn’t wait to answer.
‘At 7 o clock this evening, eastern time,
air and naval forces of the United States
launched a series of strikes against the headquarters,
terrorist facilities and military assets that
support Muhammar Gaddafi’s subversive activities’
The harsh reaction was supposed to kill the
“mad dog of the Middle East”, as Reagan
branded Gaddafi, but the Colonel came out
of the attack unscathed.
America put Libya on the terrorist-friendly
countries list and American companies were
restricted from exploiting oil there.
Nonetheless, those European companies like
Total, Repsol, and ENI kept doing their thing.
But let’s press fast forward on our story.
In 2001, 9/11 happened.
And this was a turning point for Gaddafi’s
foreign policy.
Terrorist-loving as he was, Gaddafi was inspired
by socialism, not radical Islamism.
So Osama Bin Laden was a common enemy, both
for America and for many socialist leaders.
This is how, Gaddafi started collaborating
with America by signing a nuclear disarmament
agreement, in which the leader agreed to eliminate
his country’s weapons of mass destruction.
The US declared victory, and everything was
good again.
In 2006 they even took Libya off the list
of terrorist countries.
Gaddafi was a son of a bitch… but now he
was OUR son of a bitch.
(((Please, pronounce the word “son of a
bitch” like that.
I will add some censorship on post production)))
Nonetheless, again, things changed in 2011…
THE ARAB SPRING
The Arab Spring began in December 2010 when
Mohammed Bouazizi, a Tunisian street vendor,
set himself on fire in protest against the
police.
He could have never imagined how his sacrifice
would spark a revolution.
All of a sudden, the Tunisian people started
protesting against their government, which
was another Arab socialist dictatorship.
And this inspired protesters in neighboring
countries.
Suddenly, most of the Northern African countries
were overthrowing their dictators.
Libya was not the exception.
In early 2011, a civil war broke out.
When the first winds of rebellion started
blowing towards Libya, Gaddafi even tried
to protest with the people, trying to keep
up with this “brother leader of the revolution”
image that he was so desperate to keep.
But, turns out, people could see through his
efforts.
The scent of freedom was inebriating.
Many young Libyans were fueled by the recent
toppling of Egypt’s Mubarak and Tunisia’s
Ben Ali.
That’s when Gaddafi changed his tune and
reverted back to being ruthless.
Gaddafi tells the media: 'All my people love
me.
They would die to protect me' Libyan leader
laughs off international pressure to step
down while speaking to news organizations
Within days, opposition supporters were controlling
Benghazi and the government was seeing massive
rates of defection.
The rebels tried organizing even further,
but they were being hit pretty hard by the
Colonel’s forces.
As you can imagine, Gaddafi had an army much
bigger than those 30 women from his Amazon
guard.
Libyan oil helped to pay for a lot of modern
weaponry.
And this was pretty helpful in repressing
protesters.
But, as so many people lost their lives, the
image of Gaddafi outside of Libya couldn’t
get worse.
Once again, he went from being OUR bad guy
to the man everyone loved to hate.
And this is why a coalition led by NATO’s
forces invaded Libya on the 21st of March
2011 in support of the rebels.
But it was months before NATO could turn the
tables.
As the fighting intensified, NATO carried
out a bombing campaign in support of anti-Gaddafi
forces.
The bombing forced Gaddafi to flee from Tripoli
to his hometown of Sirte, where opposition
fighters would eventually capture him.
On October 20, 2011, a video released by the
fighters shows Gaddafi begging for his life.
In another clip, the former strongman is seen
dead, with an apparent gunshot wound to the
head.
Muammar Gaddafi was caught and shot dead by
the militias of the Libyan National Transitional
Council, with the active support of French
Intelligence.
Many of you would be tempted to say SIC SEMPER
TYRANNIS, right?
Well… wait a minute.
FROM BAD TO EVEN WORSE
After the corpse of the former dictator was
dragged through the streets and put on display,
the rebels turned on each other.
The country was split, and crime and human
trafficking ran rampant.
And if there’s one rule in politics is this:
THERE CANNOT BE A POWER VACUUM.
Gaddafi was gone but… who or what was the
alternative?
Even though some western countries had been
doing good business with Gaddafi, they never
fully trusted him, of course.
They saw the civil war as an opportunity to
remove him from power and intervene militarily
in order to cut off the Arab revolution that
had flared up in Tunisia and Egypt.
It also provided powers such as France and
Britain a chance to reassert themselves on
the world stage.
After Gaddafi’s death, Libya was torn up
and divided, without a national government
to claim control.
And what that meant at the time was that local
militias now had the power of life and death
over the population.
The economy was also messed up, as one might
expect after a revolution.
The GDP collapsed in 2014 and in 2015 the
production of crude oil fell to the lowest
level on record since the 1970s.
Ex-NATO boss: Libya still a 'model intervention'
You see, unlike the Iraq or Afghanistan war,
the Libyan one was a different animal.
In this case, it was not led by America but,
instead, by France.
And the French military style couldn’t be
more different.
Usually, the Americans invade a country, kill
the dictator, and then stay there for years.
We’ve seen this in Japan and Germany after
World War II but also in Iraq and Afghanistan.
The military tries to make sure they can form
a post war government and fight the last groups
that supported the former one.
The French are pretty much the opposite.
They strike, kill the bad guy, and leave.
This is what happened in Mali, for example.
And this is what happened in Libya.
So, of course, effectiveness wise, the Libyan
war was a complete success.
In fact, if you look at this chart, you can
see that it was one of the cheapest wars in
modern history.
It took a little over a month.
Compared with Iraq or Afghanistan, the Libyan
war couldn’t be more cost effective.
So what’s the problem?
Well, the aftermath.
After the fall of Gaddafi, three main players
emerged in the country: the government of
Tripoli, supported by Turkey and Qatar, the
government of Tobruk, supported mainly by
Egypt and the Arab Emirates and, last but
not least, the DAESH forces.
War raged once more and DAESH took advantage
of the chaos, expanding rapidly.
The elections in 2014 were marred by violence
and low turnout.
Eventually, a compromise was found, and a
Government of National Agreement was formed,
sponsored by the UN.
A group that monitors violence using media
reports estimated that more than 4,600 people
have died in the fighting since the beginning
of 2014 and the U.N. estimates 2.44 million
people — about a third of Libya’s population
— have been affected by the fighting, which
has led to shortages of food, water, electricity
and medical supplies and reduced access to
health care and public services
Forgotten war: a crisis deepens in Libya but
where are the cameras?
As you might have noticed, Libya isn’t doing
much better today...
The government installed in 2016 only has
a partial hold on the country.
Given this instability, there are no facilities
and desert patrols to tackle trafficking networks.
There are also no funds for Libya's coastguard
to monitor sea crossings
And this is why, in this dangerous power vacuum,
oil companies are even starting to make deals
with local tribes in order to keep their businesses
going.
The Repsol camp in Libya resumes activity
after the agreement with the assailants
Despite all the turmoil, Repsol is still going
strong in Libya and is currently preparing
to increase production even more.
Money really does talk.
Now the question is… if even big oil companies
are making deals with rebels, does a unified
Libyan government really have a chance?
Will we ever see a democratic and stable government
in this country?
Please, leave your answers in the comment
section below.
And of course, don’t forget to visit our
friends from RECONSIDER MEDIA.Com, the podcast
that provided the voices in this video that
are not mine.
Also, remember that we publish brand new videos
every week so subscribe to VisualPolitik and
hit that bell button so you won’t miss any
posts.
If you liked this video, give us a thumbs
up and as always, I’ll see you next time!